I could hug you yeah yeah she'll give
birth
oh I sat down before you do that so rude
okay no one stands up this long I've
been doing this for 27 years no one has
ever stood up this long I don't know
what to tell you I've just I've rather
voted get involved in what's happening
here she wanted a birthday hug and I
felt like I couldn't hug that's younger
woman no I can't you can't no yeah I can
but I don't want to now you have to you
brighten up you have to go
[Applause]
easy easy watch it
save your career you saved me have a
seat there's so much to talk about
that's the first time I've ever been
there to witness a threesome exciting
threesome I'm so uptight for me that was
probably the most sexual experience I
have more cameras around when I have
them yeah you're very liberated I love
your cow blouse they're little cows all
over your blouse I'm wearing a cow bless
you know I'm like getting older I've
just gone fully insane it's a Power Move
I like power moves like this like when
you wear stuff like this people don't
argue with you we're like she does not
care argue with the lady working cow
blocks like I'm gonna lose this argument
you know so many people at work today
are wearing holiday stuff and it's
everywhere
I find this people talk about the
tension of the holidays when I was a kid
I didn't get that as I have matured into
my late 30s I don't giggle at that as
I've matured
I've come to understand that the
holidays can be stressful do you get
stressed you know I do but I drink a lot
but you know the thing that stresses me
out the most is the buying the gifts
because I feel like you have to buy so
many gifts for so many people and I
recently got in a fight with someone
because I read it I've always read if
today family has a very strong tradition
of regifter I feel judgment from you
strangers right now as dating the
monsters I see nothing wrong with it
like when I was growing up as a kid we
would get presents that had been in our
room for 10 years my parents we were
getting something you had been looking
at around the house like it was just
more like and so I would get as a gift
things that I gave my aunt like the year
before like it was like we always it was
more like a training yeah yeah and I
tried to read if something recently and
I got busted
wait.you Yuri gifted something and your
friend caught you ivorie gifted because
I had gotten a rat
a wrap gift like for a TV show we got
Kindles right we all got kindled a nice
gift super nice gift but I had an iPad
and that's - no I don't really read so I
decide is it you're too busy drinking
buying cowboy yes and and so I gave it
to a friend of mine great gift Kendall
is an incredible gift right I think he's
gonna be psyched and then he calls me
like a week later he's like is it did
you buy me this I was like yeah of
course I did
like that's of course music why is your
name engraved on the back of it oh
that's not cool I was like because I
want you to remember I love you
did that work no it's reading like bad
no I think that the same bottle of wine
probably goes to six different now did
you guys take a bottle of wine in
somebody's house and then I here's what
I do when I drink some of it and then I
report it no no you get some wine but
you got a little celebrity saliva landed
on a crime scene I think no I haven't
I've got more to do I get it stresses me
out I think it's the most as the part of
it you know and also just the
terminology around all of it I got in
trouble I love that HR sketch with your
assistant yeah last year I was working
on a TV show got in trouble with human
resources for saying Merry Christmas to
an intern is that true that's true
can get you in trouble I got I was
leaving like on the 18th or whatever
today was and I was like bye guys Merry
Christmas like just a formality what you
would say right I come back like June 6
HR calls me and they're like hey we need
to talk to you one of the interns is
pissed off that you said Merry Christmas
and I was like which by the way I was
like I don't even care how your
Christmas was it was just a formality
right but but in this in these times
were in that could like trigger someone
or offend them if it's not their holiday
as I said I was like well what should I
have said do they celebrate something
else they're like well no they're
agnostic right and I was like no no no
no you do not get to do that because had
I known that this person was agnostic
that would mean we were in a
relationship like that would mean like
we were intimately connected like I
should not know who believes in God and
who does it
I also can't guess either you know yes I
can't like guess your holiday based on
what you look like that's offensive
that's very offensive I can't be like
hey married Happy Hanukkah